[Musique]
tu m'as dit que tu avais entendu tes
parents maman tu es sorti de la maison
c'est ça en fait j'entendais pas
vraiment les mots j'avais que des bouts
de voix mais ça faisait pas les mots du
coup tu peux pas savoir si c'est une
discussion
[Musique]
il parle de tromperie
mais vous l'avez pas été l'année de sa
mort avec cette fille avec qui vous
l'avez trompé pourquoi
il y a quand même quelque chose d'un peu
étrange dans cette situation vous
admettez qu'il était jaloux
moi je préfère m'en aller tu peux pas me
dire qui était le plus énervé des deux
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire après
il fait référence quand il parle du
pillage de son œuvre vous aviez déjà
frappé votre mari non non jamais c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]